hey guys today i'm going to explain what
to expect from my academia season six
and why it's possible that for the first
time ever the entire season might only
cover one arc
in this video we're going to discuss my
predictions for the pacing of the
episodes as well as the release date but
bear in mind there will be minus
buildings ahead
i won't be giving away any significant
plot details as this is more of a
generic overview
but if you don't want to know anything
at all then i suggest you stop watching
after what i'm about to say next
before i delve into the details of my
academia season 6 i wanted to first
break down my thoughts on season five
and why it's my least favorite
from the start i'll say my criticism has
nothing to do with the quality of the
animation
as the direction of many episodes has
brought the manga to life in a way i
thought was great
for instance here's a panel from chapter
199 when ariyama gets captured
and then here is that same moment in the
anime which is 10 times more exciting
my problem with the season comes from
two main issues with the first being the
terrible terrible pacing of the episodes
thanks to repeated flashbacks recaps and
filler certain storylines felt like
they've been stretched to the limit
and for me this is what killed my height
for this season if you don't know what
i'm talking about then let's take a look
at episode 95
which is the episode where like it just
confirmed for me they were doing this on
purpose
for starters they tried to pad the
runtime by including both filler and
flashbacks that weren't in the manga
not to mention nearly a whole minute was
spent recapping the season so far
the anime original filler included
endeavoring his sidekicks chasing down a
villain
monomer taught in class 1a a track of
getting embarrassed about deku
all might looking to the sky and
thinking about the predecessors of one
for all
and class 1a giving their thoughts on
class 1b before the match
now i am usually a fan of small bits
like this that flesh out the manga
but when you combine that with the
extended flashbacks it seemed like they
were artificially stretching things out
as an example we had this flashback
halfway through the episode which to be
fair is totally canon
but why later in that same episode was
the same flashback showing for a second
time
like was that really necessary
unnecessary callbacks like this happen
throughout the season long after the
joint training arc is over
and for a seasonal anime this isn't
something i expect to see
the second main issue was that they
rearranged the order of the storylines
as the endeavor agency arc was shown
before myville in academia
they did this so they could include an
internship episode which ultimately
serves as a promotion for the third
movie
but the filler episode itself is not the
main problem by swapping the arcs around
it ruined the introduction of the new
liberation army
it lowered the stakes for my academia
and it made the anime feel disjointed
if you want a clear demonstration of
what i mean then look no further than
hawks infiltrating the league of
villains
and you'll see just how terribly the
anime ruined this early in season
5 the number 2 hero were shown to be in
contact with darby as he wanted to join
the league like i said
and as far as the audience knows the
league of villains is this organization
in episode 102 there was still no
confirmation on whether hawks had
officially joined these guys or not but
from what the anime showed it looked
like he joined a different organization
called the liberation army
the old liberation army was briefly
mentioned by gentle criminals in season
4
but nowhere in the anime was hawks ever
shown to have any affiliation with them
so him doing their bidding and working
for them generally comes out of nowhere
the following episode has shown that the
league of villains and the liberation
army are now the same thing
which again is something that has it
just has no setup whatsoever
as far as the anime showed us the league
was this small independent group that
have a big name for themselves
and yet now they're part of an
organization that has over a hundred
thousand members
with no explanation the purpose of my
then academia was to show us how and why
these two groups merged into one
but by rearranging the arcs it meant
that we were seeing the conclusion
before the argument takes place
this made the anime feel incredibly
disjointed and when you combine
all these issues it means that despite
having great animation season five has
been the most unfocused season of minor
academia so far
now moving on to what to expect from
season six it has the potential to be
the best ever
but as we've learned from this season i
mean if the studio want to mess it up
they can mess it up
the main focus of next season will be
the war which is straight up the best
storyline micro academia has ever had
this arc is longer than both the joint
training and villain art combined
so there's a small chance it could last
the whole season by itself especially if
the studio wants to add anime original
filler
the paranormal liberation war is over 50
chapters from start to finish
which is more than the 49 chapters that
were adapted during the whole season 2
but still slightly less than the amount
of chapters adapted in seasons 3 and 4.
the point is if they want to the studio
can make season six the warthog season
but on the other hand they could also
literally just speed through it if they
want however long it may or may not last
depends on how they want to pace it
and honestly it's totally up to them so
let's examine two factors that might
play into their decision the first
factor to consider is whether there's
going to be a fourth movie
and i wouldn't rule it out because you
know now we've had two consecutive
seasons where a movie has been released
while episodes are coming out
this could mark the beginning of a
pattern where there's now a film to
accompany every season
however if world heroes mission doesn't
do as well as they hope then this might
no longer be the case
this one is coming out during a pandemic
where japan recently declared a state of
emergency
so it'd be stupid to think this won't
affect ticket sales in some way
i anticipate it will still do well but
whether it meets the expectations that
were set by heroes rising is something
that isn't guaranteed
so right now i'm leaning slightly more
towards the idea of there not being a
fourth movie during season six
that's just my gut feeling because in
these unusual times for the cinema
industry
it makes perfect sense to wait a little
bit longer before pumping another one
out
pushing back a fourth movie could also
be a good thing for season 6
as no movie means there's nothing to
affect how the season plays out
the ideal scenario is that we get an
adaptation that has minimal flashbacks
and is faithful to the manga
but at the same time also expounds on it
in a way that feels relevant
if i didn't make this clear enough
earlier i'm not against filler when it's
done well
with a good example being how they
expanded on the provisional license arc
in season three
that was all extra content directly
relevant to what was going on
and they could do this in the war
because there was a lot more happening
than what the manga showed us
in the war there were two main locations
where everything seemed to happen
although the truth is there were heroes
fighting all across japan but we just
never got to see it because it wasn't
like the core battle
this provides a great opportunity for
anime original content
like seeing what shikatsu high and
certain members of class 1b were doing
during this time
anyway the second factor to consider is
whether the anime will adapt shirakuma's
full backstory from my academia
vigilantes
and while it's unlikely to happen it's
worth throwing it out there because it
would push back the beginning of the war
they've never adapted vigilante's
content before so like i say the odds of
getting his full backstory are low
but on the off chance they decide to do
it this would definitely alter how
season six begins
i reckon one and a half episodes would
be necessary to show the full thing and
do it justice
although it's more probable that they
just show a small part of his backstory
before the end of season 5.
with that said let's get into my generic
overview of how season 6 is going to
play out
as well as the two potential release
dates if you like this video so far then
i'd appreciate if you smash that sub
button and notification bell so you
don't miss future content
and remember that i'm very active on
both twitter and instagram so check me
out on there if you haven't already
i realize that i just don't plug my
socials at all so if you're interested
in following me then yeah check the
links in the description
okay so it's almost guaranteed that
season six will begin with an anime
original filler episode
and the last two we've had were actually
pretty good so i'm interested to see
what they do this time around
following this the next episode likely
won't jump straight into the war
but instead it will tie up all the loose
ends and cover content not seen in
season 5.
this will include all might midoriya and
bakago discussing the predecessors of
one for all
and possibly the students showing off
their progress it's feasible that
episodes one to three might include
filler during the kid's spring break
as that period of time was mostly
skipped over during the source material
by the end of episode 3 this is when i
anticipate that the events of chapter
259 will happen
which is when the actual fighting truly
begins that prediction is on the basis
that they don't adapt shirokuma's full
backstory
but if they decide to do that then the
battle might not happen till episode 4.
once the fighting does begin it's not
going to stop for a very long time
so i'm going to do a quick calculation
to work out how long it might last
if we use the overall arc as a
comparison that was 40 chapters adapted
over 16 total episodes
with many of the chapters being
action-packed just like the paranormal
liberation war
if season 6 was to average that same
pace then the battle between heroes and
villains would last up until episode 18
or 20 depending on if there's filler or
not
after those 18 to 20 episodes we'll
likely have an episode on the backstory
of hawks and the state of hero society
before going into another episode on the
backstory of derby and ending with a
cliffhanger about one for all
next we will learn about the true nature
of this power and midori would make a
huge decision about his future that will
lead us into the next arc
from there there should be about two or
three episodes remaining and this will
obviously begin the next storyline which
is focused on deku's movements after the
war
season 4 left us with the pro-hero arc
being incomplete and dabby didn't show
up until the beginning of the following
season
so in a similar fashion i think season 6
will end with deku coming face to face
with a certain villain but he won't
actually fight them until season 7.
finally when it comes to the release
date based on previous patterns season 6
will begin on the 2nd of april 2022
i say this because with the one
exception of season four every season of
my hero has released either a filler
episode or the first real episode
on the first weekend of april seasons
one two three and five all follow this
pattern
and unless production of season six is
affected by a potential fourth movie
i see no reason why it shouldn't be the
same on the off chance they are actually
making another movie though
then in theory the release date might be
pushed back to sometime between
september or december of 2022
let me know down below how excited are
you for the next season why you academia
and do you share my opinion that season
five was placed badly or do you think it
was perfectly fine
whatever you think don't forget to smash
that sub button if you haven't already
and until the next one
peace out